monsieur roy bonsoir bonsoir d'abord
votre première réaction elle annonce
d'aujourd'hui à cette entente
aujourd'hui soulagé c'est une très bonne
nouvelle pour l'industrie porcine
canadienne
oui soulagé mais soulagé complètement où
il ya encore des choses à régler compte
tenu des tarifs douaniers qui demeure
toujours en place absolument c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour l'industrie de façon
générale mais faut considérer que le
port et le prix du port de caen
lorsqu'on le vent est calqué sur le prix
américain
donc oui une question de tarif vert
principalement de la guerre commerciale
entre les états unis et la chine puis
également il ya une seat une probation
sais plus et c'est une ouverture
confusion dans laquelle on va être
surveillé donc on devra être très très
précis sur les livraisons qu'on va faire
il ne doit pas y avoir d'erreur dans les
certificats il ne doit pas tout tout
doit être vrai à 100% est venue des
enjeux là dessus c'est pour ça que la
chaîne avait décidé de suspendre ses
importations
ça a été le premier la preuve le premier
sujet qui a été soulevée de la part de
la chine concernant nos exportations par
la suite
considérant le temps il ya eu d'autres
questionnements qui sont venus par
rapport aux hautes tensions
diplomatiques mais c'est aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui est soulevé le de faire de
faire attention sur les exportations la
façon qu'on va le faire puis
l'exactitude dans nos documents parce
que vous pensez qu'il ya plus de tension
diplomatique de tensions entre les deux
pays que ça ça a joué davantage que les
éléments peut-être un peu plus
administratif
comme les histoires de falsification de
ou de certificats qui était faux
c'est difficile à dire de notre de notre
angle de notre point de vue sur le
terrain nous ce qu'on espérait c'est que
ça recommence le plus tôt possible
il n'y avait pas de raison que cela
arrête considérant la qualité du produit
con con qu'on fait au canada
donc si nous ce qu'on espérait 6 et
repartent le plus le plus tôt possible
c'est toujours difficile dans la balance
la peut-être que des politiques pourront
être plus facile allez les politiciens
seront plus en mesure de répondre à ce
type de questions là dans notre camp on
voulait faire parler plus tôt possible
quelle est la valeur des pertes
encourues par les producteurs de porcs
du québec en raison de l'embargo on
estime que dans la période des quatre
mois il ya eu ça représente 120 millions
de dollars qui ont été perdus de la part
des producteurs et la danse on exclut
toutes les industries khi qui a perdu
énormément aussi puisqu'on a envoyé dans
cette période avant l'embargo et on
pouvoir commencer maintenant on envoyait
des portions des partis du parc y
étaient difficiles à valoriser dans le
dans d'autres marchés que celui chinois
donc 120 millions de perte au cours des
derniers mois fait pour le québec
exact et pour l'ensemble du canada est
ce que vous avez le chiffre on n'a pas
le chiffre exact ce qu'on avait estimé
lequel la période code de tensions
commerciales avec les états unis
s'étaient plus de 265 millions avant
avant le début des élections donc cesser
des pertes majeures pour l'industrie
porcine pour les producteurs
puis on est on est très satisfaits de
pouvoir avoir accès à nouveau à ceux à
ce marché et donc quand on parle du
québec par rapport à l'ensemble du
canada le québec représente combien
quelle part des exportations de
l'ensemble du canada en termes de port
vers la chine
on est ont produit environ 30% de la
production totale du canada puis on est
là produit est la province la plus
importante en termes de production et 30
% de la production totale du canada de
porc de produits du porc pour la chine
c'est en un ratio à peu près égal je
pourrai pas aller dans les détails dans
les fins détails du calcul mais de façon
générale
oui on représente environ la même
proportion que notre production est ce
que des compensations ont été demandés
au gouvernement est ce que le
gouvernement vous entendu là-dessus oui
il ya un groupe de travail au niveau au
niveau de garde au gouvernement
ma fédéral conquis a été mis en place
pour se pencher sur les pertes qu'ils
ont été encourus par les producteurs
notamment dans un contexte de
compétitivité asymétrique où les
etats-unis eux ont compensé leurs
producteurs donc et en étant donné qu'on
est dans un marché aussi intégré entre
les états unis puis le canada on a
demandé à ce qu'ils aient une aide qui
soit apportée aux producteurs canadiens
pour qu'on puisse faire face à une
compétition féroce de la part des
américains pendant l'embargo est ce que
les producteurs ont réussi à trouver
d'autres marchés
c'est plus au niveau des transformateurs
qui laissait plutôt les transformateurs
qui pourrait répondre à ces questions là
l'information que nous on a c'est que
les partis qui étaient difficiles à
valoriser à l'extérieur du marché de la
chine pour certaines portions ont dû
être récupérés donc recyclé dans des
produits de moindre valeur ajoutée en
protéines wingles le premier ministre du
canada dit que la reprise des
exportations est effective dès
maintenant est ce que c'est le message
que vous avez reçu également oui c'est
le message qu'on a reçu et combien de
temps ça va prendre là pour faire la
transition et revenir marché dit normal
ça va dépendre aussi le glas de la
rapidité de du marché chinois arrêt à la
réouverture
nous de notre côté on va il suffit juste
de rediriger nos produits vers la chine
on avait un très bon couloir de
transport de logistique donc de leur
mettre en place ces peaux très long
cependant il faut clé tout le système de
régulation de règles soient mises en
place rapidement pour qu'on puisse
ouvrir piqué pas de frictions entre le
canada et la chine
et vous personnellement comme éleveur de
porcs est ce que vous avez senti les
effets de cet embargo sur vos activités
à vous personnellement en tant que
producteur de porc étant donné qu'on est
basé sur un prix américain c'est plutôt
là
les lacunes la tension entre les
etats-unis et la chine c'est à ce moment
là que nous on a vu une diminution
importante de notre prix pour vous
donner un ordre de grandeur dans l'aisne
l'automne pour l'automne de cette année
automne 2018 on a perdu environ 50% de
la dette de notre valeur de pour notre
part lorsqu'on veut lorsqu on vendait
aux transformateurs
étant donné qu'il y avait une colonne
tensions grandissantes entre les états
unis et la chine à cause des tarifs
douaniers pour la machine exactement
l'ailé
les vases communicants ce faisant elle
ya une demande moindre pour le porc
américain celles affectées directement
notre notre valeur donc à ce moment là
on a on l'a senti très fortement dans
l'hiver il ya une embellie ça s'est
amélioré on croyait qu'on aurait un
marché chinois très ouverts puis très
très fluide et la porte qui nous a été
claquée à ce moment alors c'est clair
que c'est pas une bonne nouvelle pour
notre l'industrie parce que pas
seulement la production il ya aussi la
transformation et ces deux maillons qui
doivent travailler ensemble
monsieur roy merci beaucoup pour ses
explications ce soir plaisir merci
monsieur fillon